der Zustrom der Migranten die illegalen
vor allem über die Balkanroute nach
Sachsen kommen reist nicht ab die Arbeit
ist für die Bundespolizei kaum noch zu
schaffen
wird von frühmorgens bis später abends
also egal eigentlich 24 Stunden am Tag
der anhaltende Migrationsdruck
überfordert viele Orts die Bevölkerung
es kann nicht sein wie in Hirschfeld das
so und so viel Ausländer bekommen und
die Dorfbevölkerung ist ja viel weniger
der Bundeskanzler riskiert den
gesellschaftlichen Frieden und zwar
sehr ernsthaft
wir sind mit der deutsch-tschechischen
grenzstreife auf Schleierfahndung im
Dreiländereck zu Polen und Tschechien
unterwegs
Oberkommissar Rene boriskowski von der
Bundespolizei spricht perfekt
tschechisch sein tschechischer Kollege
Jan schapolitsch lernt gerade Deutsch
aufgrund des anhaltenden
migrationsdrucks werden sie in Sachsen
von der Bereitschaftspolizei aus dem
gesamten Bundesgebiet unterstützt die
Kollegen aber die hier an der Grenze
helfen die fehlen dann an andere Stelle
die
unterstützungseinheiten selber kommen ja
aus Bereichen in denen auch noch andere
Aufgaben
zu erledigen sind wie zum Beispiel die
mobilen Kontrollen Überwachungseinheiten
der Direktion die im Fußball eingesetzt
werden es ist illusorisch zu glauben
dass beides zusammen zusammen noch mit
anderen lagen die auftreten können wie
Demonstrationen und sonstiges die Bundes
ja permanent irgendwo anstehen dass das
noch mit den Verbänden und der mobilen
Kontrollen Überwachungseinheit
abzudecken ist über 12.000 Menschen sind
allein im ersten Halbjahr nach Sachsen
illegal eingereist mehr als doppelt so
viele wie im Vergleichszeitraum vor
einem Jahr meist allein reisende Männer
lebensgefährlich sind die Bedingungen
unter denen die geflüchteten geschleust
werden hier standen 26 Menschen bei etwa
50 Grad eng zusammengefasst und
völligehedriert in einem kleinen
Transporter 10000 € zahlen Sie im
Schnitt für die Flucht die Schlepper
gehen dabei immer das grob elloser
vorliefern sich Verfolgungsjagden mit
der Polizei ein Mensch kam dabei in den
vergangenen Wochen bereits ums Leben
fakt ist dass die
ja Schleuser die momentan über die
Grenze kommen und agieren in ihrem
Umgang bzw in ihrem Fluchtverhalten ja
massiv
an Brutalität beziehungsweise
schonungslos im Einsatz des Fahrzeuges
als Waffe teilweise
kaum noch zu überbieten sind also wir
leben eigentlich täglich das Schleuser
versuchen
zum einen zu entkommen zum anderen aber
auch
Polizeifahrzeuge teilweise gerammt
werden
oder abgedrängt werden und das ist eine
Situation die kaum kaum erträglich ist
was die Nationalität der Schlepper
betrifft dazu erklärt die Bundespolizei
in Ebersbach größte Gruppe der
Nationalitäten die Schleuser umfassen
leicht aus der Ukraine kommen dazu
diverse andere Staaten wie Usbekistan
Tadschikistan Georgien
da kommen die Schleuser her oder es
werden halt Landsmänner die bereits
schon in Deutschland sind die sich
hinreisen lassen um ihre Angehörigen
beziehungsweise Landsmänner dann ins
Land zu holen also das sind dann die
Hauptgruppen die jetzt sowieso schon
aufgetreten sind wie Syrer Afghan
je mehr Kollegen im Einsatz sind
desto mehr Migranten werden aufgegriffen
und in sogenannte bearbeitungsstraßen
wie in Hirschfelde zuerst Erfassung
gebracht
hier reicht die Tafel für die Anzahl der
geflüchteten die an einem Tag
registriert werden nicht mehr aus sodass
sie auf den Fliesen im Gang
weiterschreiben müssen
hier wird im Stationsbetrieb werden die
erfasst die werden registriert es werden
die Personalien festgestellt es wird zum
Beispiel hier in den Raum hinterher
kennen uns diese Behandlung durchgeführt
das heißt wir werden Fingerabdrücke
genommen die werden überprüft in den
Datenbank ob die Personen schon irgendwo
mal Einlegen der Straftat begangen hat
oder vielleicht in einer anderen
europäischen
die Männer die sich hier erstmal von den
Strapazen ihrer Flucht ausruhen werden
dann schnellstmöglich innerhalb weniger
Stunden in eine
ernsthaftnahmeeinrichtung wie z.B
Dresden oder Chemnitz gebracht auf so
viele geflüchtete jeden Tag sind sie
hier nicht eingestellt und so ist vieles
provisorisch die Kapazitäten reichen
einfach nicht
auf Familien auch kleine Kinder
dreijährige Kinder auch das hatten wir
schon die bedürfen dann natürlich in
einer besonderen vorsorgen von uns dann
die bekommen Spielzeug z.B die werden
separat untergebracht hier in einem
anderen Raum zum Beispiel einer
kleineren Zelle da gehen wir schon drauf
rein
nur unwein von hier im Hirschfelder
Ortsteil Rosenthal sorgt eine geplante
Asylunterkunft in einer ehemaligen
Spinnerei für Protest 120 Einwohner gibt
es hier kaum Infrastruktur 150
Flüchtlinge sollen kommen das sorgt für
Diskussionen auch im benachbarten Zittau
es kann nicht sein wie in Hirschfelde
das so und so viel Ausländer bekommen
und die Dorfbevölkerung ist ja viel
weniger ich denke dass das Problem
überhöht wird und das Angst gemacht wird
und er wird eigentlich nur das gesagt
was Angst macht alles andere wird
weggeredet und die Situation dass
vielleicht Familien kommen dass
vielleicht nicht so viele kommen das
wird ja gar nicht wahrgenommen ich
brauche die nicht
meine Meinung da stehe ich auch dazu ist
okay wenn Leute herkommen die Hilfe
brauchen aber das muss halt geschaut
werden ob es wirklich ist
bedürftige Menschen sind
der Görlitzer Landrat Stefan Meier hat
vergangene Woche einen Brief an
bundesinnenministerin ferser geschrieben
und stationäre Grenzkontrollen gefordert
die Antwort steht noch aus
wenn es nicht die Grenzkontrollen sind
dann soll sie alternative Vorschläge
machen aber ich höre halt ein großes
Schweigen beim Bund und es muss jetzt
auch klar werden wie die Finanzierung
künftig geregelt ist deswegen kann ich
auch nicht akzeptieren dass der
Bundeskanzler erst im Herbst die
Ministerpräsidenten dazu widerspricht
dass es viel zu spät
Sachsens Innenminister Schuster fordert
ebenso dass der Bundeskanzler umgehend
handeln muss Menschen in diesem Land
fühlen sich sowohl weil das ein
Rechtsstaat ist weil unsere
rechtsstaatsprinzipien
Vertrauen ausstrahlen und
Verlässlichkeit in dieser Frage
verlieren wir dieses Vertrauen weil
Schengen nicht funktioniert und wir sind
Europa nicht hinkriegen ich erwarte vom
Bundeskanzler dass er dieses enorm
relevante Thema endlich selbst in die
Hand in der Bundeskanzler riskiert den
gesellschaftlichen Frieden und zwar
sehr ernsthaft Fehler und sind Sachsen
macht sich Unmut breit weil sich
zahlreiche Kommunen aber auch viele
Menschen jetzt mit der Integration
zunehmend überfordert sehen
kein einreiseanspruch und dann wird auch
zurückgewiesen das ist das was die
Menschen erwarten denen geht es nicht um
die AFD und dann geht es auch nicht um
das beschimpfen von Asylbewerbern die
wollen sehen dass dieser Rechtsstaat
funktioniert und nicht alle Gesetze
einfach geschliffen werden
da könnte der Bundeskanzler der muss er
reagieren weil es gibt eben Maßnahmen
die schnell greifen
Verhandlungen mit Afghanistan Tunesien
kann auch er führen und die meisten
Flüchtlinge kommen erst noch
erfahrungsgemäß in den Monaten September
bis November René boriskowski und seine
Kollegen hoffen jetzt dass die Politik
Sie nicht im Stich lässt und endlich
handelt